欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们接着讲关于产品优化的实战方法
这里也是根据四项线来进行优化的
这里面主要根据的指标是点击跟访客这两个维度来进行展开优化的
你还记得我们之前讲过一个产品优化的主线吗
从曝光量到点击到访客
再到一个群盘
还有贴目
再到订单
是吧
这个主线还记得吧
前面我们已经讲了关于曝光点击
这两个核心指标的一个重点的问题优化
这里面是有一个点击率的嘛
前面这部分我们已经讲了
那么接着就是来讲
访客到群盘贴目的这两个维度的重点优化
因为它数据呈现是这样的
先从曝光跟点击这两个维度进行优化
优化了之后它会转化到这边访客到群盘
这两个指标也会存在问题所以也需要优化
我们把访客到群盘这个阶段的数据进行优化了之后
其实对订单的一个转化也会有所提升的
所以相当于你优化了这个就已经会促进这个订单的提升
这个整体的结构还是比较简单的还是围绕着这条主干线来进行优化的
所以我们记忆东西的时候就记住这条主干线就可以了
你按照这条主干线的指标然后根据它呈现的数据
再去采用具体的方法针对性的优化就可以了
那么这节课我们主要是针对高点击高访客但是它是低寻盘
低TM咨询的这些产品进行优化
这里面有一个衡量的指标就是寻盘总化率
这个指标一定要理解
那么接下来我们来重点看一下各个象限具体要怎么去做
第一象限就是需要我们重点支援服饰
比如说你的点击量是低的访客也是低的
但是它的寻盘是非常高的
这种情况说明什么呢
说明很多人喜欢你们这个产品
受到了市场欢迎同时很多人来咨询
那么我们如何让这个好的产品更好呢
也就是让这个产品获得更多寻盘跟TM怎么样去做
第一个我们要增加它的点击量跟访客
因为它之前是被人看到的机会太少了
那么我们就要让更多的人看到这个产品
第一个如果这款产品是我们公司的主营产品
你的关键值覆盖也比较广
我们直接就把它加入推广
精准推广它就可以了
那么这个就有利于拉升它的点击量
是不是有可能就增加它的寻盘或者是贴门了
那么第二个就是你的关键词标题覆盖的词是非常少的
这种情况
如果它的寻盘还没有达到你的标准
或者是说
它的寻盘平时都是一到两个
你想再增加一点点
但是流量太少了
那么这种情况你可能去增加一些流量关键词
还有推广提升流量
也就是说你可能去改一下它的标题
改一下它的标题T
然后把这个更多的有流量的词
精准的词加入到标题
然后直接去推广
记住你改标题的时候一定要去进行推广
拉升它的流量
不然你会发现
很多时候你改了标题如果不推广
就会导致它流量下降
效果会更差的
所以一定要记住这个逻辑
改标题就要想办法马上去推广
第三个就是你要去增加它的访客
你看这里是访客吧
那么我们可以通过EDM营销
访客营销
报RFQ直播
把这些产品挂上去
那么是不是有效增加它的访客
那么增加访客的时候
相当于你就增加了它的寻盘跟贴母
第四个就是支援的扶植
你看支援的扶植
比如说加油橱窗是不是能够有效地提升A这个产品
它的一个关键层的排名
关键层排名是不是更有利于被别人看到
看到了是不是更容易得到点击
加油组营业认产品
这些都能够拉升它的产品的防客
所以说这个板块就是针对性的支援扶植就可以了
针对这些低点击的产品
高寻盘的产品
那么第二个象限
我们是不做优化的
我们要重点关注
点击量很多
访客也很多
寻盘很高
贴母也很多
这种产品通常是什么产品呢
一种是
它是一个爆品来的
或者是实力品来的
这种产品我们就先关注
不要去优化
因为它这些数据的维度都是非常好的
那么它的寻盘和上级的转化率在6%以上
就相对来说是比较好的
当然你也可以去参考一下
里门这个行业
它的一个寻盘转化
或者是说商机转化率
到底在哪个维度
如果你达不到这个的话
那么你就参考行业的
商机转化率
或者是寻盘转化率就可以了
不硬度一定说
一定要比6%
为一个其实的标准
你要参考一下行业的
有些行业它低于6%的
那么你就参考行业的就可以了
第三象限
这个板块的话
我们是不优化
做重点调整
就像我们刚才讲的
高曝光低点击的情况
那上线的一样了
比如说这些点击量也很低
循环也很低
相当于这产品没流量
比如说发超过60天的
我们就不要优化了
因为我们刚才也讲过了
它是不会获得很大的流量的
那么在30天以内的也是直接改标题
所以说只要效果差的产品也就是说啥数据都没有的
你发产品在30天以内的
要么你去优化要么就放弃
直接去重新发产品重新去找池就可以了
这样的效果会来得更快一点
第四项线关于高点击
也就是说你这个产品
好多人都点进来了
点进来了
但是它没循环
如果你这个产品又是推广的产品
是不是会浪费大量的金钱
所以这个板块是要重点去优化的
那么怎么样去优化呢
我们下面有一个具体的步骤
那么我们来一个个来看
第一个维度就是我们要判断数据的标准要先明确
比如说你的周点击在30个以上
单日超过10个以上的点击量
这种就是算是高点击的情况
如果你的店铺里面
本身流量很少比如说冷门行业很少
那么你就没有必要按照这个数据维度去判断
你可以30往下降一点10往下降一点点
这些数据维度去判断就可以了
所以你一定要
先确定一个
自己
店铺的一个
判断的标准
你自己定一个数据根据你店铺的实际化来定就可以了
先定数据第2个操作
我们去判断这个产品
A产品它的访客国家是否精准
精准的就不用优化了
不精准的则去优化
比如说A这个款产品你是卖给美国的是吧
如果
你的访客都是美国
就说明他精准
如果他的访客是非洲的
那么这种情况
你就要去优化了
比如说你
用直动车锁定你的目标国家美国
让所有的点击积累在美国
那么就可以扭转
他的整体的一个国家标签的问题
那么第2种情况就是
如果是自然流量来的
这种情况我们可以再继续观察一段时间
如果他还是非洲的
这种情况
我们可能就要去采取一些措施
比如说
这个A产品有很多的点击词
点击量非常高
到非洲来的点击
那么这种词
我们可能就会在标题中可能做调整啊
或者是说
我可以直接
保持这个链接
我在价格
起定量等方面提升一点
让这些什么非洲的
不敢点我的产品
就这种情况
其实还有很多种优化的方法
那么在这里就不展开讲了
第三种情况就是你要去判断这个产品
他的一个点击词是否精准
那么这些词是推广的词呢
还是自然流量的词呢
你要综合去判断在产品360
里面去判断
如果是推广的词的话那么你就要去针对
自动车综合的调整了
这些方法我们之前都讲过或者是说在自动车板块都有讲过
如何结合产品分析360和自动车分析去优化
等于优化
你去优化这些就可以了
如果是自然流量的词怎么办
如果像自然流量的词就像我们刚才说第二种情况的时候说的方法可以参考
那么第四种就是你的产品的起定量跟价格产品词营业内容的呈现
这些都是会影响到你的产品的转化的
我们在前面讲
关于产品优化的时候
第二小节目也讲过相关的内容
那么你直接参考那个板块的内容就可以了
比如说你的访客非常多但是巡盘非常少的情况下你要去看一下价格起定量这些跟同行的差距在哪里
会不会是你的起定量跟价格都高于同行太多
第二种就是你的产品详营业
台版的内容
是不是足够的吸引客户
或者是说你可能是凭感觉自己放产品详营业的内容
没有根据买家的需求和他的一个需要解决的问题去呈现内容来吸引他呢
那么这种情况都会导致你转化率很低
这种情况呢我们可以增加
比如说优位券折扣券
公司实力的展示这些来维度来提升我们的
群盘量
那么第五种情况比如说你这个产品
A是推广的产品是吧
那么你的
访客国家是准确的
关键值也准确的
你觉得详情业问题也不大
那么很有可能就是
你的直动车的推广的人群
招签的问题
比如说你推广的这个直动车是吧
池
访客
详情都没什么问题
起定量价格都没什么问题
有可能就是你推广的人群比如说人群
B人群C人群D人群比如说A人群是高点击的
这种情况我们可能就要降低他的溢价来降低他的
一个
点击量
降低他点击量
B人群C人群D人群
B人群他的点击量不是非常低的情况下
我们直接提升他的溢价来增加他的点击量
增加他的点击量
来测试一下
那么我们
这个BCD这三类人群
会不会转化更高
人群是转化低的吗
已经验证了转化低了
所以这种情况是其中的一种优化方法
当然
可能还有其他的
相关的方面的需要进行综合的调整
那么这里我们只讲关于这个标签的优化
那么第六种就是
不优化的情况
我们要用店铺最好的
趋势的产品款式来承接流量
比如说A产品他点击量非常高是吧
本身他这个产品不是我们很想要的
我们在他的产品详情页里面
关联一些我们店铺的爆品相关的产品来去承接一下这部分的流量
或者是说把他这个产品在详情页里面设置一些导流的模板
引导去主页PC的首页
或者是APP的店铺里面去
看我们的别的产品
也就是做一些
间接去
引导到别的界面就可以了
这个就是不需要优化
中上我们就是关于点击
和寻盘转化这个维度
进行优化的
那么这里面重点优化什么
重点优化在第4个项线
这个我已经备注底色了
你多去操作几遍根据这个流程
那么你不需要记得很牢
但是你只要理解了这个原则
那么你
也是很
快就能够掌握具体的方法
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
我们下节课再见